existe um livro chamado tal de shin que
há milhares de anos ele ensina coisas ao
povo chinês através de parábolas a
primeira vez que ouvi falar desse livro
foi através de uma história conhecida
como a história da velhinha chorona
era uma história que contava que eu ache
mantida existe uma senhora que todos os
dias ela permaneceu no mesmo lugar
chorando sem parar milhares de pessoas
passaram todos os dias por elas
perguntavam o motivo daquele fenômeno
um dia um chinês resolveu para perguntar
velhinha porque você chora tanto ela
disse pra ele eu tenho duas filhas uma é
casada com vereadores a passo
a outra é casada com o vereador de
guarda chuvas
quando chove eu choro porque eu sei que
o meu jorge mendes a passo não vai
vender nada
é a minha filha vai passar fome já
quando faz só o choro porque eu sei que
o meu dinheiro que vem de guarda-chuvas
não vai vender nada
a minha outra filha vai ter de esperar
mais uma senhora cada vez foi só a
senhora deveria sorrir porque uma das
suas filhas vai comer toda vez que chove
a senhora deveria continuar a sorrir
porque vai ser a vez da sua outra filha
como a história terminou dizendo que
dizem que a partir daquele dia haverá
choro nunca mais chorou
a princípio essa é uma história
extremamente simples você perguntar a
moral desta história você vai me dizer a
gente teve o lado bom da vida você vai
dar certo essa é uma moral da china
nessa história
só que eu precisei de 10 anos pensando
nessa história a conseguir compreender
qual o grande ensinamento que existia
então entendi o poder de uma história e
eu vou diretamente com vocês um pouco da
minha jornada espero que quando menos
dez anos da vida de vocês e vocês
compreendam a final comigo o que existia
por detrás então poderoso e se é desse
momento do rio de janeiro
um pobre meus avós meus tios meus pais
moravam na linha do trem
meu pai era morador do morro do borel a
minha mãe ela teve amiga se tornar
prostituta meu estômago traficantes
o engenheiro da engenheira química da
ufrj numa época em que a mulher se
tornava dinheiro
ela foi a primeira pessoa que me ensinou
que você faz o seu destino para visitar
minha vó eu trago meus amigos por lá a
gente falava vala de esgoto brincando
tive amigos foi reconhecido pelas roupas
e eu tenho um golpe de faca na altura do
pulmão que ela vem no lugar do meu
melhor amigo a pessoa que eu prometi que
daria minha vida um dia se preciso fosse
quando você cresce um lugar sem
consequências da austeridade você
aprende que o amor fica mais forte mas a
dor por exemplo uma garrafa
a sorte da minha família é que eu tinha
um avô que era um contador de histórias
ele passava os filmes antigos então
casablanca os brutos também amam era
aquele menino do cine paradiso ele me
contava histórias antes de dormir
então ele me tornou um contador de
histórias ele faleceu dia tem cinco anos
mais ou menos mas é muito forte a
memória dele e os seis anos eu passava
de um novo herói e aí foi quando eu
conheci brooks e les ele mudou a minha
filha eu vi a operação dragão aos seis
anos em que houve mais de mil vezes eu
prometi que seria tudo que ele era eu
seria escritor eu seria faixa preta e ia
trabalhar com cinema às artes marciais e
encerrou aos 6 e aos 12 era instrutor da
academia e dessa forma como professor
só que lá em casa a gente tinha mais um
grande problema na minha avó ela sofreu
do mais alto grau de alcoolismo que eu
já vi uma pessoa ela foi fazer
exatamente conta disso os meus braços
após chegar embriagado uma vez cair
bater e abrir a cabeça e então por conta
disso esse problema que foi na nossa
família até para escrever os dragões de
éter um livro e um projetor já deixava
uma bolsa do lado uma uma roupa qualquer
coisa de momento que ela entrasse eu
tinha que sair de casa
e aí eu tinha duas casas uma hora do
jogo de artes marciais a outra maria
faria que tinham até onde era o meu
refúgio onde podia ler os livros que não
podia comprar então eu a marcar os
livres e depois voltar no dia seguinte
continuar avalia que alguns de vocês já
fizeram isso né
e aí eu acabei tentando trabalhar
naquela livraria como não me contratar
para trabalhar de graça ajudar os
vendedores e ajudar a estimular os
clientes a escolher o livro limpa para
as mesas não entender por que as pessoas
que pegam esse livro não aquele e
sonhando um dia meu livro vai estar aqui
eu entrei na faculdade de cinema para
aprender a escrever para cinema e
comecei a jornada
mandei meu dragões de éter um lado
mandava eu já ter exposto ninguém queria
lembrar que quem tirar meus roteiros e
foi acusado em todas as editoras a
primeira editora que me acusou foi
editora rocco e depois de uma série de
seqüências de de cartas que dizem que
apesar das visíveis qualidade editorial
e seu original ele infelizmente não se
enquadra na linha pólo do editor
ninguém leu um livro nem mesmo ter que
eu vou fazer eu vou estudar a história
dos grandes autores
e aí eu vi que todos eles tinham uma
coisa como um todo estiveram plano que
tinha tudo para dar errado
eles apostaram tudo então vi que era
isso que eu precisava de um plano louco
e tivesse tudo para dar errado e
apostasse tudo aquilo
o plano brilhante que eu tive foi o
seguinte eu ver quem é o autor mais
vendido do brasil eles publicam um cara
chamado augusto cury e cury havia
acabado de nossa primeira ficção dele o
futuro da humanidade
eu li o futuro da humanidade eu falei já
sei você é o cara que vai levar esse
livro cinema para ver se ninguém fosse
nada e aí o projeto com o nome do curu
alguém vai querer ler o roteiro eu vou
ter uma história tal posso tirar o
editor falar olha eu acho que ele viu o
filme então leu meu filho era uma idiota
mas era o que eu tinha aquela é investir
tudo e fui atrás na bagagem só tinha uma
vantagem no primeiro ano de faculdade
inscrito o roteiro chamado em arranjos
em suas mãos
eu tinha recebido um prémio de mérito da
associação do tenistas norte americanos
era o que eu tinha foi debaixo do braço
cheguei na esposa do couro bastante
impressionada com a maneira que eu
queria vender aquilo tal e e depois eu
entendi então eu tinha um prémio de
mérito de hollywood
ela achou que era um roteirista de
hollywood ela pergunta pra mim acho que
a gente pode apresentar um roteiro com
mel gibson é claro
daiane passou por um agente
internacional do cori dilma tem o mesmo
nome do duro de matar só podiam makley
depois é até que o jogo também ficou
impressionado com a maneira que eu
estava querendo vender aquela história
ea filha dele mas vou procurando rio de
janeiro na palestra
eu peguei o grande dragão branco meu
capitão 92 pedras pedaços foi até lá
assistir assisti aparecido por lá na
ilha do governador quando acabou foi uma
tela fila de professores cenecista
entrei na fila com o meu livro debaixo
do braço
quando chegou a minha vez eu sabia que
eu tinha um minuto para mudar a minha
vida
então minha mãe não cala a boca ao
escutar o goleiro passa a conhecer
alguns cruzam fazer a coisa mais
racional do jn acordo cansa de falar com
a família de kadhafi já falei que a
gente procura ficar para sempre por ter
salto né
rio de janeiro foi o facada nesta
tendência aqui e aí eu bati na mesa e
falei eu quero utilizar o futuro da
humanidade
e aí com essa atenção assim por medo por
bom senso coisas no meu livro falou pra
mim é lógico porque não tinha feito meia
hora de roteiros em impedimento não
entrevista depois de falar com a minha
fazer uma postura boa procura grande eu
sentar para negociar o direito de pedir
nada nessa aí que cheguei fernando
meirelles
só que merece há cinco anos a agenda é
por algum tive uma intuição eu achava eu
tente chegar no cláudio torres na época
costa já tinha feito redentor com pedro
cardoso mas é uma intuição promotora
vânia roteirista de cidade de deus tropa
de elite que me ajudou só pra achar que
eu merecia ele falou poxa meu amigo
falar de você falou mesmo falou após
escrever pra ele
só que escrever pra ele era diferente
que hoje a internet banalizar aquela
época na internet dedicada e só quem
viveu internet discada sabe como é que é
ela é você conectar depois da meia noite
foi paga por só leva que domingo quando
tentava ball aí que tentava mas não
conseguia ficar em pé e se ele entrar no
chat da obra fala aí gatinha tc lembra
essa é a cena e sei que é fazer o cada
vez na mensagem é essa é um talento se
imagina não tinha internet mas aquela
pontinha mec
internet como é que não esperava que os
computadores velhos que eles tinham
espalhado pelas lojas e aí eu ia também
é que dona odilá da praça espanha
esperava as pessoas começam as promoções
se recolhendo as notas ficais última
hora de internet da marca inter net
escrevi posto e também na internet ea
resposta dele e ele tinha ficado
impressionado com maneira também está
tentando vender aquele outro falou quero
ler liga pra minha secretária sai do mac
donald foi até um orelhão liguei pra
configuração se uma das maiores
produtoras da américa latina ea
secretária de falar a verdade o código
perguntou se é que a gente mude um carro
buscar o roteiro eu não era faltando
aqui na minha agenda amanhã entre três e
quatro horas em uma reunião há aqueles
que já aprendi também que quer parecer
importante mil divisão office tem a
reunião que vai ler o roteiro no avião
as duas coisas sem chave pode anotar
isso aqui é uma dica valiosa
então aí que acontece eu passou então
esse período pode me pedir semanas para
eu vou ter duas semanas depois ele
escreveu ele tinha ficado tocado com
aquele roteiro ele tinha terminado
chorando o fim da mocinha é o diálogo e
um do pará dor e então eu entendi minha
intuição ele havia passado na família
dele os problemas parecidos com que
aquele personagem passava naquele livro
e aquela história falava com ele vai
fazer que nem só de mim eu eu gosto do
que eu faço essa história só que não
depende só dele
depois de conversas com sócios do
consórcio dele ele estava indo fazer
aquele roteiro fazer uma comédia que ele
próprio estava escrevendo
no fim das contas eles chegaram à
conclusão de que uma comédia no brasil é
comercialmente mais viável
e foi assim que cinco anos depois estava
no cinema a mulher invisível mas o fato
de ele ter dito aqui na frente da gente
procura e eu faço eu vou ter aqui no
mundo tudo aí o agente do curso comigo
então no aeroporto não tinha telefone
mas eu tinha o agente internação do
curso que tinha o nome de uma cláusula
do de matar
o corpo estava no planeta naquela época
era bem estava estourando e aí eles
estão querendo entrar nesse setor
foi assim que dragões de éter chegou e
tudo começou o trajeto contudo tinha
tudo para dar errado o presidente do
planeta ele queria portal livre pela
metade
depois ele olhou e foi eu sou é é
um ator brasileiro de literatura
fantástica estreante é muita coisa na
frança só o livro foi lançado com tanto
descaso que eles esqueceram o código de
barras do livro e por último a grande
estratégia de marketing
estiveram e vamos lançar o livro junto
com o último harry potter tem idéia do
que é enfrentar harry potter na livraria
eu tenho era maior que os vendedores não
dava um chapéu seletor na cabeça é
porque você ia pegar o ônibus tinha um
pôster o filme vem ainda valeu ele não
vai sentir culpado e é bom que as mesas
era se ele não fosse harry potter a guia
para entender o mundo após a copa do rei
para trazer para o cachorro é estimular
o poder só isso tem que ter uma invasão
e não tinha como se aquele bruxo de
ponta a primeira é off já tem pena de
off ea cicatriz na cabeça a gente pega o
busão lotado então uma plataforma
deltana pagar pela justiça na escola é
muito má é muito mais legal então tinha
tudo para dar errado
só que naquela época tinha o finado
saudoso orkut e aí foi lá no orkut que
tinha aquelas comunidades que o facebook
até hoje não conseguiu a força daquela
comunidade tipo através daquelas
comunidades que foi indicado por outro
indicando da gorjeta de repente sem
que a planta entender porque se eu
tivesse uma entrevista com mesma foto
tivessem código de barra
eu estava seis meses os autores mais
vendidos da história planeta
e aí depois aquele editor que me
descobriu foi pra abrir editora leya e
anos depois o voo estava lá em franco
comendo cachorro quente na fã na feira
do livro de frankfurt em 60 paulo rocco
na minha frente e conseguiu contar
histórias e aí acabou que vem aquela
coisa na cabeça caramba
o vôo foi o primeiro que recusou e
tantos anos depois eu me tornei a maior
negociação da história do autor nacional
da editora rocco então de tudo que tudo
isso que eu passei
o que eu mais gosto mas aprendi e vou
ver a minha relação com meu pai meu pai
foi a primeira pessoa que eu disse que
esse escritor primeira pessoa disse que
murray enquanto a mãe de verdade é que
no futuro ela quase sempre só que eu
tive uma mãe que quando ele disse que eu
ia morrer de fome
ela falou então nós vamos passar fome
até ele conseguir
e aí tudo o que eu fiz de atrás do curto
está eu pensei que eu soubesse de nada
renan então era sempre só eu e minha mãe
quando eu assinei meu contrato eu sentei
para contar pra ele se lembra de uma
história de um menino um fenômeno
de 12 anos o jogador que assinou com a
nike eles lembraram foi lá que eu
comentou comigo que deixa a cabeça de um
pai no momento desde que ele se lembrava
eu disse pra ele pois é a cara do filho
fez a mesma coisa você não sabe
então eu contei pra ele soltou mais
jovem assinar com o sexto maior grupo
empresarial do mundo e você não sabe
ele perguntou se era por isso que eu
tinha ido a são paulo faleceu
influenciar meu contrato
ele comentou que o problema é que você
leva tanta porrada da vida
uma hora você esquece o valor do sonho e
acho que pelo que compreendia isso o
cara veio do morro do borel foi um filho
falar pra vocês que estou a viver disso
é que estou eu falar vou mostrar pra ele
mas eu também tive que aprender a
importância das descidas a gente carrega
muitos de nossos pais nossos filhos vão
carregar muita gente e se ele não tinha
mais um sonho daquele direito de votar e
nem que tivesse que dividir o meu então
quer dizer o meu pai é um fanboy
cinqüenta não faz a cabeça da água
direto mas vai pagar ao site que ele
experimente se aquecer e primeiro time a
se manter seu décimo grau que se
encontra no natal fora de casa pode
fazer pra comer lembra aquela coisa de
roupa todo mundo e chegou lançamento
bienal do livro de 2007 ele foi lá e
botar a camisa que ele mandou fazer
comentou condenar meu filho comentou
quando estava orgulhoso estou contente
já tinha visto ele estava vetado final
das contas e pediu para ir embora que
foram já viveu demais e eu vi que eu
precisava agradecer a ele por ter ido
nem abraço nele e ele foi no dia
seguinte ele morreu
a última vez que falei com o meu pai
nessa vida durante o lançamento serão
jec na bienal do livro do rio de janeiro
em que ele foi até lá ele viu o livro
ele colocou a camisa que mandou fazer
ele comentou quando ele estava orgulhoso
ele disse que já tinha visto que
precisava ver a última coisa que eu
falei com o meu pai nessa vida é
agradecer a ele por ter ido disse
obrigado pai e como fica a cabeça pessoa
momento de se ver a batalha de 20 anos
para cumprir a promessa que tinha feito
quando bruce lewis 6 e na semana que eu
cumprir aquela promessa tinha enterrado
meu pai era o melhor ou o pior momento
da minha vida convivendo naquela semana
ele foi enterrado com a camisa que ele
fez cobrindo ele como se fosse uma
bandeira e naquela semana eu fiz o
lançamento porque a melhor maneira de
respeitar sempre vai ser continuar
eu preciso de um tempo a colocar a
cabeça no lugar para tentar entender o
que a vida queria me ensinar o que
aquele caminho que eu queria para a
minha carreira como artista como pessoa
pública como força do que me lembrei me
lembrei da história da vila chorão e aí
eu entendi a história da velha chorando
porque foi aí que quando você começa a
pensar naquelas coisas de justiça de
vilhena como funciona isso
essa balança te dá um grande tiro grande
eu compreendi lembrando daquela história
que o grande ensinamento na hora que
você deve ver o lado bom o positivo
sempre das coisas
o grande lançamento daquela história era
que milhares de pessoas passaram todos
os dias pela violência urbana e foi
preciso que só uma delas parar e
perguntar se da linha porque você chora
tanto pra mudar com isso o resto da vida
dela então que eu aprendi nessa jornada
foi exatamente isso que apesar do meu
pai nunca ter lido um livro meu ele
havia sido o primeiro leitor porque ele
havia sido a primeira pessoa a minha
jornada a ser servido de exemplo no fim
meu pai voltará a sonhar e é isso que
acredito que seja um livro um livro é um
sonho que é transmitido de diversas
maneiras
ele é um sonho um sonho do próprio
escritor então o que eu posso
compartilhar com vocês hoje do que eu
aprendi na minha jornada até aqui
exatamente sobre isso que no fim das
contas é por mais que doa por mais que
seja difícil por mais austero que seja
realmente o amor fica mais forte a dor
fica mais rápido mas mais do que isso
no fim das contas não existe
de justiça existem escolhas a gente pode
fazer porque no fim das contas o que eu
aprendi é que todos nós temos o mesmo
tempo que todos os outros
nós temos uma vida nem mais nem menos